En este video me gustaría ver si podemos
demostrar que el triángulo DCA es congruente
con el triángulo BAC ( Δ DCA ≅ ΔBAC) . Pausen el video y tratende resolverlo por su cuenta. Muy bien, trabajemos
juntos en esto. Veamos si podemos resolverlo.
Estas pequeñas flechas nos dicen que el segmento
DC es paralelo al segmento AB y podemos ver este
segmento AC como una especie de transversal a
través de estas rectas paralelas, y sabemos que
los ángulos alternos internos serían congruentes,
por lo que sabemos, por ejemplo, que la medida
de este ángulo es la misma que la medida de este
ángulo: estos ángulos son congruentes.
También sabemos que ambos triángulos,
tanto el triángulo DCA como el triángulo BAC,
comparten este lado, y que por reflexividad va
a ser congruente consigo mismo; entonces, en
ambos triángulos tenemos un ángulo y un lado
que son congruentes. ¿Pero podemos descubrir
algo más? Bueno, podríamos estar tentados a
argumentar que este lado es paralelo a este
porque se ve paralelo, pero no podemos hacer
esa suposición sólo con base en cómo se ve.
Si supiéramos eso entonces podríamos hacer
algunas otras suposiciones sobre algunos otros
ángulos aquí y tal vez demostrar la congruencia,
pero resulta que, dada la información que tenemos,
no podemos simplemente asumir eso porque algo
parece paralelo o porque algo parece congruente.
De acuerdo con la información que nos han dado en
realidad no podemos probar congruencia. Ahora
déjenme hacer una pregunta un poco diferente:
digamos que nos dieron un poco más de información,
digamos que nos dieron la medida de este ángulo
que tenemos aquí y que es de 31° y que la medida
de este ángulo es de 31°, ¿podemos demostrar,
ahora, que el triángulo DCA es congruente
con el triángulo BAC? Veamos qué podemos
deducir ahora. Bueno, sabemos que AC está en
ambos triángulos, por lo que será congruente
consigo mismo y déjenme escribir eso. Sabemos que
el segmento AC ≅ AC, está en ambos triángulos,
y eso es por reflexividad, que es una forma
elegante de decir que algo es congruente consigo
mismo. Ahora, también vemos que AB es paralelo a
DC, igual que antes, y AC puede verse como parte
de una transversal, entonces podemos deducir
que este ángulo CAB, déjenme escribir esto,
es congruente con el ángulo ACD (∠ CAB ≅ ∠
ACD), porque son ángulos alternos interiores,
ángulos donde una transversal interseca dos
líneas paralelas. Así que para ser claros,
este ángulo CAB es congruente con este ángulo
ACD, y ahora tenemos dos ángulos y un lado,
dos ángulos y un lado que son congruentes. Así que
ahora podemos deducir, por el postulado ángulo,
ángulo, lado, que los triángulos son realmente
congruentes. Ahora sabemos que el triángulo DCA
es realmente congruente con el triángulo BAC
debido a la congruencia ángulo, ángulo, lado,
de lo que hemos hablado en videos anteriores.
Para ser claros, a veces a la gente le gustan
las pruebas de dos columnas. Puedo hacer que esto
se vea un poco más como una demostración de dos
columnas al decir que estos son mis enunciados
y este es mi razonamiento. Y hemos terminado.